gpus are finally starting to surpass
MSRP with gtx 1060 s going into 100's
and gtx 1070 is going into the 200s
however GT 1080 and 1080 eyes are still
very unbel because it's pretty much
impossible to find them and even if you
can't find them they are very very
overpriced ask for the art txseries well
no one should really buy a period and
ask for it AMD side of things the RX 500
here is actually pretty decent and
pretty well priced but Vega just isn't
really the best thing that you can buy
so I would stay away from it but let's
be honest right here
there is no GPU that you could buy right
now that wall price that you couldn't
have gotten for the same price last year
so should you buy a GPU right now
[Music]
welcome to hari sadhus fortunately there
are many GPUs that are set to come out
from both Nvidia and AMD very soon ask
for NVIDIA has been a couple of months
since the launch of the RT X series and
there still is no 2060 and 2050 variants
so those Bears should be coming out very
very soon many rumors are suggesting
that the 2060 and 2050 will not have
great racing technology and this dust
makes sense logically because of the
2017 and 2018 and 2080 T I can't really
run great racing technology very well
there is no way that 2060 would be able
to there are also rumors that Nvidia may
launch of Fallout 11 her series which is
pretty much identical to a twin series
but without r8 crazy technology this
would be a lot for a plane to consumers
because these cars would be a lot more
cheaper without their really expensive
with great racing harbour inside it and
India may actually go do this because in
the last couple of months their stock
price has over half even if that doesn't
happen there is definitely a 2016 2050
coming up very soon so that definitely
is something to look out
AMD also seems to be coming out with
something very soon they just recently
launched rx 590 but that's pretty much
the same as the Oryx 580 just with some
minor upgrades
there are several rumors suggesting the
AMD you will want to new high-level
series and see
yes some rumors are suggesting that this
new series will be navi fixed Nagas
originally set out to come out at the
end of 2018 and it's about time for it
to come out some other rumors are
suggesting that this new series will
actually be another Vegas series on the
7 nanometre architecture along with gdr
six memory either way there seems to be
something vacant from MD very soon that
will make their high-level series much
more favorable if you're looking to buy
a GPU right now you really only have two
series to pick from the tensors from
Nvidia and the arc 500 series from AMD
and even minute 10 series the 1080 and
napi are currently not very good options
so for the 10 series it really comes
down to 10 70 or below now the 10 series
and 5 corner series are really both
great sets of cards and will last you a
very long time especially for gaming a
1080p the only downfall for those cards
is that in a couple of years promotes
those cards you will have to probably
turn on the graphics level the other
thing is that these cars are a couple of
years old now and they really aren't as
cheap as you would expect to find them
so in the end you can buy a GPU right
now and you will not be ripped off and
it will serve you very well for the next
couple of years however it's not a great
deal or anything there are some new
cards are coming out from both these
companies so you may want to wait for
them because they may provide more
performance for the same price something
else to keep in mind is that once these
new cards release current generation
cards and drop in price so in a couple
of months from now you may be able to
find the same car that you're looking at
right now for a little bit cheaper so
going back to the original question
should you buy a GPU right now well if
you really need a GPU you don't care
about a little bit more performance or
saving a little bit more money then yes
you should go ahead and buy one you
definitely won't be disappointed and
these cards let's interview well however
if you can wait and you should wait till
CES this there are several cards that
may come out which may give you more
performance or save you a bit of money
but that's just what I think what do you
guys think are you guys going to be
ready to buy a GPU or are you guys going
to be buying one right now make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments I'm
curious as to what you guys they
so make sure to post your thoughts also
if you guys like this really make sure
drop a like and consider subscribing if
you like see more videos just like this
one but I'll let I'm hearty I'll see you
guys on next
[Music]